[Music]
hey everyone welcome to harry potter
theory today we're going to be
discussing harry potter actor
replacements as a series that spanned an
entire decade it's no surprise that
warner bros found itself forced to
recast actors and actresses you might
have noticed some of these but others
probably passed you by
today we're going to take a look at all
the recastings big and small and see
what changed between the films let's
dive into it 15. griphook grip hook was
one of the many goblins who found
himself working within gringotts
wizarding bank just like his
predecessors had done since 1474
griphook handled the finances of some of
britain's wealthiest wizards and witches
eventually during the rise of the second
wizarding war he would find himself
without a job and incidentally
responsible for the death of many of his
fellow goblins
in the films vern troyer was the first
actor to portray the goblin banker his
version debuted in 2001's harry potter
and the philosopher's stone
troyer was famous at the time for his
performances in the austin powers movies
where he played a smaller clone of dr
evil mini-me but when it came time to
film the final movies in the harry
potter series the deathly hallows parts
one and two the producers decided to
recast the role
they wanted to make sure the entire cast
was british so they decided to rely on
one of their current actors to fill in
for vern
warwick davis who already portrayed
professor flitwig took on the added
responsibility of bringing grip hook to
life 14. parvati patil pavarti was one
of harry potter's fellow housemates and
best friend to lavender brown during the
escalation of conflict between the
ministry and the death eaters parvati
eventually went on to join dumbledore's
army
in the films parvati first appeared in
prisoner of azgaban and was portrayed by
sitara shah at the time
but by the time gobert of fire went into
production she was replaced by shefali
chaudhary
when we look for a reason for sitara's
seemingly rushed replacement we can't
really find anything
it's not unlikely that she stepped away
for personal reasons or her management
simply failed to negotiate better terms
13. padma patil padma was parvati's twin
but unlike her sister she wasn't sorted
into gryffindor instead the sorting hat
thought ravenclaw was a better fit but
that didn't stop her from playing a
crucial role in the war against
voldemort
just like her sister she joined
dumbledore's army and fought against the
death eaters
now in the films padma was actually
enrolled in gryffindor to make things a
bit simpler at first in the prison of
azkaban the actress sharon sandu
portrayed padma but in later films
afshan azad took over duties again we
can't really be sure why the producers
decided to recast her but it could have
been for any number of reasons
12. lavender brown
lavender brown is one of the most tragic
heroes from the final years of the
second wizarding war
as a student in hogwarts she was close
with the patil sisters particularly
bombardie and at one point when ron
weasley wanted to make hermione jealous
lavender became ron's girlfriend
tragically by the final year of her
education voldemort laid siege to
hogwarts and the werewolf fenrir
greyback murdered her
in the films lavender brown was actually
portrayed by three different actresses
and the recasting caused quite a
controversy kathleen cauley first played
her in chamber of secrets and then
jennifer smith played her in harry
potter and the prisoner of azkaban but
in harry potter and half blood prince a
new actress jessie cave was brought in
the problem with this was the first two
actresses were black and jessie was
white
in the minds of many film fans this
meant that the producers were white
casting a black role but the creative
minds at warner brothers tried to
explain their decision
by claiming that the original two
actresses were cast as lavender brown in
name only they were basically just
extras or small speaking roles and the
producers had just assigned the extras
with existing names from the harry
potter books instead of giving them new
names so in their minds they never
actually intended for those earliest
casting decisions to apply to lavender
brown when her role was eventually
expanded into a love interest for ron
weasley 11. angelina johnson angelina
johnson was one of harry potter's
favorite upperclassmen she was two years
above harry and was actually one of his
quidditch team captains during his time
at school
eventually angelina actually became
harry's family when she married george
weasley becoming harry's sister-in-law
in the movies angelina was originally
portrayed by an actress named daniel
tabor in the philosopher's stone chamber
of secrets and prisoner of azkaban but
there was a problem
since angelina would eventually become a
love interest for george weasley
danielle's extremely young appearance
was kind of off-putting the producers
felt that a romance between george and
danielle would come across as
unbelievable at best and creepy at worst
so they recast the role in favor of
someone who looked just as old as the
weasley twin
tiana benjamin took over from the goblet
of fire
10. alphaius doge
elthias doge was an old school pureblood
wizard who stood opposed to the rise of
death eaters and lord voldemort during
the final months of the second wizarding
war doge wrote an obituary for his dear
friend albus dumbledore and kept up
appearances with many prominent
gryffindor families in the movies doge
was first portrayed by the accomplished
stage and television actor peter
cartwright in the order of the phoenix
but he was replaced by david ryle later
during the filming of the wedding
sequence in harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 1
9 fat lady the fat lady is a hogwarts
staple a sassy portrait guarding the
entrance to the gryffindor common room
with the gryffindor common room password
spoken aloud the fat lady admits whoever
utters the words into the room actress
elizabeth spriggs was initially cast in
the role but when alfonso quaron took
over as director he recast the fat lady
to british comedian dawn french
8. alicia spinach alicia spinach is a
very minor harry potter character that
often appears in the background but
never utters any lines for this reason
many actresses have played the role of
alicia spinach a gryffindor student who
started at hogwarts in 1989.
two actresses have been credited with
the role first leyla sutherland who
played her and he philosopher stone and
next rochelle douglas who took over in
the chamber of secrets
7. katie bell katie bell was a classmate
of harry potter's she was sorted into
house gryffindor and was a member of the
gryffindor quidditch team serving as one
of its chasers
during the second rise of voldemort
katie joined dumbledore's army and
fought in the battle of hogwarts
in the films the role passed through the
hands of three different actresses at
first emily dale played the role in
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
and its sequel harry potter in the
chamber of secrets but later when the
role was reduced a completely unnamed
actress stepped in to bring her to life
in prisoner of azkaban
by the time harry potter and the half
blood prince was put into production a
new actress georgina leonidas took over
young harry potter fans probably
recognized the actress from her years of
starring on the basil brush show as
molly
6. voldemort the dark lord himself was
recast in the middle of the harry potter
series at first voldemort was portrayed
by actor richard bremmer you probably
remember him as the strapping redhead
viking from the antonio banderas film
13th warrior bremer brought voldemort to
life with the help of cgi in harry
potter and the philosopher's stone but
was later replaced besides the series of
young actors who portrayed voldemort in
flashbacks rafe fines was the main actor
to bring the villain to life as an adult
his tenure as the dark lord began in the
finale of harry potter and the goblet of
fire and continued on until deathly
hallows part two
5. bill weasley bill weasley was the
eldest weasley child born as early as
1970
he attended hogwarts between 1982 and
1989 and during this time it became both
a prefect and head boy
he's only mentioned in passing during
the first couple of books as he lives in
egypt but when arthur wins the daily
prophet's grand prize galleon draw
the family is able to visit him
it's at this point that we see him in a
weasley family photograph
in this photo bill is played by actor
richard fish however he is later
replaced by actor domino gleeson
donnell gleason is the son of actor
brendan gleason who plays madai moody 4.
pansy parkinson pansy parkinson was a
slytherin witch in harry potter's year
at hogwarts the parkinson family were
purebloods and members of the sacred 28
a list of 28 pureblood wizarding
families
during her time at the school pansy was
both a prefect and a member of the
inquisitorial squad
in the first couple of films pansy's
role is fairly benign and she's mainly
just a background character in draco's
crew the role was first filled by
actress genevieve gaunt i know perfect
name for harry potter casting next by
actress lauren shotton and finally and
perhaps most recognizably by actress
scarlett byrne
3. professor dumbledore albus dumbledore
was perhaps the most famous recasting of
them all
richard harris portrayed the actor in
the first two films the loss of a stone
and chamber of secrets but after the
irish actor passed away in 2002 the
producers were forced to recast
after a long search they settled on
michael gambon who played the character
all the way until the deathly hallows
part two as an interesting note between
the two both of the actors actually
weren't english and instead were born in
ireland
this is a rare departure from warner
brothers attempt to accurately cast
performers based on characters at
fictional home towns dumbledore was
undoubtedly english as he was raised at
first in a small town called mold on the
world and after moving godric's hollow
2. tom the innkeeper
one of the minor roles to be recast was
that of tom the innkeeper in the novels
tom was known as the proprietor of the
leaky cauldron an ancient pub in inn on
the threshold of diagon alley while
working there tom had a chance to rub
shoulders with some of the most famous
members of the wizarding community
in the films tom was first portrayed by
an english actor named derek deadman who
was popular for his performance as ringo
in the 80s series never the twain but
his brief appearance in philosopher's
stone wasn't enough to keep him from
getting replaced as he produces eyed a
new actor for the role this time they
chose jim tavares who gave one of my
favorite performance from a minor
character in the entire series
you might remember tavari's version of
tom escorting harry into a room within
the inn and while the minister of magic
gave harry a lecture tom humorously
offered plaint after plate of food 1.
helena ravenclaw helena ravenclaw was
the daughter of one of hogwarts four
founders rowena her life was cut
tragically short when she was murdered
by her mother's acquaintance
but in death she remained at hogwarts in
paintings and as a ghost in the
philosopher's stone and the chamber of
secrets helena was portrayed by a young
actress named nina young
but when it came time for her appearance
in the deathly hallows part 2 the
producers decided to recast and actually
turn to kate winslet for the role
since it was probably too small of a
part winslet turned it down and actress
kelly mcdonald instead took it up and
that's it for this video which of these
surprised you what video do you want
next leave a comment down below
until next time remember
it matters not what someone is born but
what they grow to be
[Music]
[Music]
you